So far in this final exam we've written a lexer, a
parser and now in this problem we're going to write an
interpreter. However, we're mixing it up a bit and we're not
going to write an interpreter for a programming language per se,
but rather for a market. We're going to be given a
list of how much money people have, things that they want
to buy, and things they're willing to sell. And we're going
to simulate the market and the result is going to be
the amount of money that people have left over. So
let's take a look at an example input into our interpreter.
So here I have our abstract syntax tree for our
market. At the beginning we declare how much money Klaus and
Andreas, are two participants in the marketplace, have. And then
we talk about what are they willing to buy and sell.
Within each element, we generally say, who is the person
that this element applies to. The what, this element is dealing
with, and then some amount of money. So for the
has elements, we're saying Klaus has 100 coins. And we're saying
Andreas has 50 coins. Down here we're saying Klaus wants
to buy a sheep for 50. He also wants to buy
another sheep for 50, you can have more than 1. Andreas
wants to sell a sheep for 50, and he wants to sell
another sheep for 50. So Klaus wants to buy two sheep, each
for 50. Andreas wants to sell two sheep, each for 50. We
should probably be able to make a deal here. Note that
after the has elements, the buys and sells can be in any
order. So let's step through this by hand and see if we
can come up with an algorithm for which to write our interpreter.
So here we're saying Klaus has 100 coins. We should probably
keep track of that since the output of the entire interpretation
is going to be a list, of how much money each
person has. Or actually, we're going to store it as a dictionary, but,
so let's do that. I just wrote Klaus for short. So,
we say Klaus has 100, okay. We are done with this,
we don't need it anymore. This next line says Andreas has
50, so let's update our dictionary. All right, we're done with this.
Now that we see Klaus wants to buy a sheep for 50.
Let's see if anyone is willing to sell a sheep. So, let's
go through the rest of them one by one. So we, in
this next line it's about Klaus buying. We don't really care about
buying, we're looking for selling. Okay, here we have a sell, it
happens to be for a sheep, and it also happens to be
for the exact amount that we want. So, these three elements match
perfectly for what we're looking for. One more thing that we have
to check is to make sure that Klaus has at least
50 coins to make the transaction. So, we look up here,
Klaus has 100, that's more than 50, he's able to afford
it. So, now we do the transaction, Klaus now only has
50 and Andreas now has 100. We should cross off the
elements that we used. Now let's continue the process from the
top again. So, we only have two things left. So, the
next one is Klaus wants to buy a sheep for 50.
We do the same look up, go to the
next element, see sell sheep 50. Yay. Klaus has
at least 50, we're all good. Let's make the
transaction. Okay. We've gone through everything in our parse
tree. There's nothing left to do because there's nothing
left. So, our output is just going to be
this dictionary. So, we went through that algorithm, it's
pretty straightforward, it's a matter of just stepping through what
is available, and doing what we can until there's
nothing left. So, now you're probably thinking, where's the code?
Well, let me show you. So here I have the
solution. It may look a bit messy, but it's actually
pretty straightforward. The first thing we do, is declare the
dictionary that we store how much money that each person
has. And the basic strategy like I went over is
to continue going through elements in the parse tree until
there's nothing left to do, until we didn't do anything and
so nothing's changed and we should just stop. In the case
of the example that I went over, that just meant that
we were out of elements, but it could also be the
case that no one can afford to buy anything, so we
should just stop. So let's assume that there's nothing left to
do, and then only change it once we do something. We're
going to go through each element in our abstract syntax tree.
We're going to pull out who is involved in
the element. That's always the zero index, the first element
in the tuple. We're going to do what kind of type it is, okay. If it's a has. So
those are going to go first. We're going to
put that person in our environment. And then what I'm
doing right here, is we're just marking off it
as skip. We're changing the type to skip. Skip isn't
has, buy or sell, so we're just going to ignore
it. This is equivalent to me crossing it off. An alternative
way of doing a similar process would be, to recursing onto
the parse tree and removing parse tree elements, as we use
them. But this is, just as easy. If we're in
a buy scenario, if we find an element for which we
want to buy, we're going to take out what we want
to buy and how much it's for. And then we're going to
go through the abstract syntax tree again. If
we find an element in the abstract syntax tree
that is a sell, it's what we're looking for.
I can afford it for that price, and it's
the price that I want to pay for
it. We're going to do the transaction. This involves skipping,
crossing off. Both elements in the parse tree that
are involved in the transaction. Subtracting off the new
cost, and adding that amount of money to the person that sold
it. And we're also here putting finished equals false, because we did
something. The state has changed and we should do another pass. And
once we're done, we just return the dictionary that we started with.